but my my thought was whenever I put  together a panel I always like putting  opposites like I always want to see the  most conservative and the most liberal  person put them out of room to get them  I I've always wanted to do a panel of  corn stars and nuns I just think it'd be  funny and I feel like the nuns like what  are the nuns even gonna say to the porn  stars it would be great for sure but it  I mean if you're a nun don't you kind of  at a certain point just be like okay  like this is my thing I'm not gonna  really try to tell the corn Stars what  to do no I went to Catholic School some  of the notes somewhat somewhere they're  like people you know some people would  someone it's just an interesting it  doesn't have to be a debate it doesn't  have to be heated but you can just ask a  question that they both would have a  different opinion on and then it's  interesting